turning now to the state of Alabama
where the first ever death row execution
via nitrogen gas has been performed it
was the state's second execution attempt
on 58-year-old convicted murderer
Kenneth Smith after a failed lethal
injection in 2022 Smith was executed for
the 1988 capital murder of Elizabeth
dorlene Senate in Calbert County please
confer with the media Witnesses for
Smith's last words Smith was pronounced
deceased by positions at
8:25 p.m. Central Standard
Time Kenneth Smith made a lengthy final
statement it began with tonight Alabama
CH
Alabama tonight Alabama caused Humanity
to take a step
backward he continued saying I'm leaving
with love peace and
light thank you for supporting me love
all of
you while everybody's sitting there
waiting for Christmas and all excited
about Christmas our
family our family was waiting for the
courts to decide the fate of my husband
and whether he was going
to
suffer or were we going to stand up and
do the right
thing our son
was
crying having just watched his
father take his last gasp for
air the media is sitting behind us
shuffling papers and talking about
time my question to you guys is where's
the
humanity where's the compassion
where's love and
forgiveness nothing happened here today
is going to
bring uh mom
back
nothing um it's kind of a Bittersweet
day we're not going to be jumping around
hooping and hollering hooray and all
that that's that's not
us but U we're glad this day is
over